i didn't know this about you but you
were a magician as a kid
so what kind of magic did you do i was a
dove artist
i would do things with animals i would
produce a red white and blue
trio of doves and then turn them to the
american flag i had a lot of cute things
in my act
and by the way that picture was when i
was like 15 but when i was 11
it was my first brush with late night
because i sent johnny carson a letter
and asked him if i could do magic on the
show and
it's funny because you gotta stay
diligent and you gotta
dream years even though they turned me
down that day
years later i ended up sitting with
johnny promoting
coming to america one and we did
magic tricks for each other during the
commercial he did a coin trick for me
and i did a coin trick for him and him
being my idol
made that probably the second best
moment to sitting with kelly on the
floor in a hallway
that's amazing that those are nowhere
comparable want more fun stuff
i thought so check out these videos
floating around my head
this one is really cool i'm just saying
no pressure